[Music]
welcome to a special 2023 staff's Choice
episode where Ron Tomato's very own
recommend their favorites of the year
that we haven't yet covered on what to
watch which means some of these are
going to be off the beaten path some you
may never even heard of so open up your
notes app you're going to want to type
these down would you be able to be a
good juror for this matter sir I'm I'm
uh racist sir please have a seat I don't
know why I said that eliminate that for
the next time totally yeah it's a stupid
idea first up is the reality hoax sitc
jury duty this Amazon free original
follows a guy named Ronald going to jury
duty only he doesn't know that everyone
there is an actor except for him and
everything is being staged with that
they plan unexpected events to test
Ronald which makes for some
unpredictable story lines and is a great
first reason to actually show up for
this jury duty the first season is
certified fresh on the Tomato Meter with
an even higher audience score and to
help validate all that stuff even more
is the fact that it's up for a couple of
Emmy Awards and including outstanding
comedy series and outstanding supporting
actor for Marsden rod and tomatoes media
coordinator Emily catlet summoned this
recommendation and here's what she has
to say about it this sitcom turns the
mundane experience of jury duty into a
rius comedy serving up hilarious Antics
quirky characters and shows you the
authenticity and simplicity of Being
Human once you start the show you can't
stop thanks Emily and good luck to the
poor souls who actually have jury duty
in
January
also available for your viewing pleasure
is the South Korean reality competition
series physical 100 on Netflix and
reason number one to watch this show is
that it features an Eclectic mix of 100
athletes of all different types from
Olympic Champions and bodybuilders to
military soldiers and fitness YouTubers
who compete in a series of physical
challenges in order to determine who has
the most ideal physique unlike like
American reality TV which doesn't always
bring the a-listers if you know what I
mean a lot of the show's competitors are
well known and respected in their fields
and they're all super encouraging if you
now all of a sudden feel guilty about
everything you ate on Christmas you can
thank Ron Tomato's senior editor Ryan
fujitani here's what he had to say about
his choice it's a fascinating experiment
that offers a generous dose of gripping
drama and a refreshingly Earnest
depiction of genuine sportsmanship
somehow managing to be both wholesome
and intense at the same time did anyone
else think he was describing their
family Christmas party just
now next is the action thriller flick on
Netflix Jaan this Hindi language Indian
film is led by India's most famous movie
star Shah ruk Khan AKA srk or our
favorite King Khan who plays a Jailer of
a woman's prison trying to fix societal
corruption what a son opsis the movie
has set box office records as the
highest grossing Indian film of 2023
naturally a sequel is already in
development as well so you might as well
get ahead of it all right now you're
welcome chosen by Ron tomato supervising
producer edric Dale Sila this is what he
has to say about Jawan if you have yet
to witness the great king KH this will
be a great start driven by a powerful
moving story and garnished with
Incredible action set pieces Jaan is
worthy to be placed above most action
films put out in the world West this
year he's been struck by a car it's more
of a nudge you're looking at around
$112,000
$112,000 it's a
dog that's a lot next up is an
Australian comedy series you can find on
Paramount plus called Callin from
accounts and the first reason to try
this one out is if you're already in
love with shows like crashing and you're
the worst this 30-minute romcom Falls
right in the same vein with two topnotch
comedic performances the show was
created by and stars the husband and
wife team of Patrick bral and Harriet
Dyer and in this romcom their real life
chemistry and Inspirations fit nicely
into the story including their age Gap
and the fact that they really did name
their dog Colin from accounts got to
love it and with a certified fresh
Tomato Meter score hovering around 100%
it's no surprise to find this one in the
top five of our best TV of 2023 list at
Ron tomatoes.com and to know that a
second season is in production Callin
from accounts comes from Anthony Alisa
who is a producer for RT and he says if
you want another traditional meat cute
series with characters with upstanding
morals you shouldn't watch this but if
you're looking for one of the best shows
of the year that will make you laugh out
loud and features two refreshingly
comedic performances this is for you
thanks Anthony and don't you worry don't
think most of us know what a moral even
is that's like a tooth or something
[Music]
right
and here it is folks the final
recommendation of 2023 the Japanese
superhero film Shin com and Ryder first
off this movie is about a man and his
female cohort who are trying to take
down the evil organization that turned
him into a mutant cyborg aren't we all
besides its strong Tomato Meter and
audience scores it's also based on the
common writer franchise which spans 53
years and includes anime liveaction and
other multimedia series if you know know
this wreck comes from Ron Tomato's
review curator Rob Fowler who says
stylistically aping anime action with
inventive film making rather than a
bottomless budget Shin Comm and Rider is
a wholly unique and surprisingly moving
piece of entertainment oh he also leaves
an end note here don't tell your uncles
you're watching this they'll hurt
themselves fishing out their Shin common
writer figures from Storage Rob you're a
gentleman and a scholar well that's it
your last five recommendations of 2023
from the staff here at Rotten Tomatoes
thank you all so much for tuning in all
year round we can't wait to help you
manage your watch lists in 2024 be sure
to let us and your fellow viewers know
in the comments what your absolute
number one show and movie of 2023 was we
might have just opened a Pandora's box
but whatever let's go out with a bang
remember to check out Ron tomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large that
is all for today and the year fresh
family see you next week in 202 4 yikes
have a fantastic New Year and as always
stay
[Music]
fresh